le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
le réseau routier réunionnais bénéficie
d'un moyen de transport reconnaissable
entre tous le réseau car jeunes sa
mission relier les principales villes
entre elles pour permettre aux
réunionnais et aux touristes de se
rendre sur les lieux de travail d'étude
ou d'intérêt quotidien tels que les
commerces ou les sites de loisirs depuis
le 11 décembre 2014 le réseau car jaune
a fait peau neuve pour se recentrer sur
ses missions et ainsi améliorer la
rapidité et le confort de ces lignes en
lien avec les autres réseaux de
transports en commun qui doivent assurer
les déplacements au sein d'une même
ville ou au sein d'une communauté
d'agglomération quelles sont les
innovations et changements concernant le
réseau car jaune on en parle tout de
suite dans lien social
depuis le 11 décembre dernier le conseil
général propose de nouveaux services
pour mieux répondre aux réalités et
besoins des déplacements des usagers sur
toute l'île
redéfinir le service réseau car jaune
sur sa vocation interurbaines améliorer
la qualité du réseau et amener une
nouvelle clientèle en proposant de
nouveaux tarifs abonnement et services
une mise en place progressive
s'effectuer un nouveau plan fait l'objet
d' analyse systématique afin d'adapter
et d'optimiser davantage le réseau
coralie renard nous expliquer les
innovations du réseau car jaune
aujourd'hui en place ce nouveau réseau
plus performant
l'idée de se déplacer à tout moment à
travers toute l'île graphe daily express
et semi express adapté et ce pour une
tarification unis 2 euros quelle que
soit la distance parcourue cette
évolution du réseau interurbain car
jeunes permet encore plus de proximité
entre les réunionnais par des trajets
plus rapides et plus directs entre les
différentes villes de la réunion elle
améliore également de manière
performante efficace et cohérente la
mobilité quotidienne de ceux de 22 mille
usagers cette évolution s'applique de
plus sur une tarification adaptée à la
situation de chacun afin de permettre
les déplacements de tous et du plus
grand nombre les étudiants et jeunes et
demandeurs d'emploi et les familles
bénéficieront de tarifs réduits les
anciens combattants invalides de guerre
ainsi que love personnes à mobilité
réduite et personnes âgées de plus de 65
ans bénéficieront de la gratuité sur
l'ensemble du réseau
yannick bonnefont directeur de
l'exploitation car jeunes nous dévoiler
les exigences concernant l'arrivée des
nouveaux bus aujourd'hui en ligne les
exigences techniques sont principalement
liés à la mise en service d'un parc de
69 véhicules neufs inédit à la réunion
et répondant aux normes exigées en
termes de sécurité ainsi qu'au respect
des normes environnementales
l'ensemble de nos personnels sont des
personnels issus de l'île de la réunion
qui ont été formés sur place par nos
équipes de formateurs sur le plan
technique la volonté affichée s'appuie
sur trois aspects majeurs
l'accessibilité c'est à dire des
planchers bas et ce six sert à la fois
aux personnes valides mais également à
celles qui sont ce qu'on appelle des
personnes à mobilité réduite et
également des personnes en fauteuil
roulant pour les poussettes les
handicapés on la comprend plus soirée
au prix d'avant et nous on n'a plus de
contacts avec eux aussi c'est mieux le
deuxième point important pour nous c'est
la sécurité parce que chaque véhicule
sera géolocalisés il disposera à bord de
caméras de vidéoprotection de manière à
apporter plus de sécurité à nos clients
les conducteurs quant à eux disposeront
pour leur protection d'une vitre anti
agression qui jusqu'à présent il
n'existait pas sur les réseau car jaune
on a tenu à ce que l'ensemble de nos
véhicules
soit le plus satisfaisant possible je
prends juste un exemple la ligne est
claire ouest ira de saint pierre à saint
denis sans aucun arrêt entre ces deux
gars on ira à la même vitesse qu'une
voiture l'intérêt c'est que la personne
qui avait jusqu'à présent l'habitude de
prendre sa voiture pourra voyager sur la
ligne est claire en utilisant sa
tablette puisque tous les véhicules
seront équipés d'un système wifi à bord
qui leur permettront d'avoir accès
soient leurs mails ou à d'autres
informations il me trouve qu'elle est
meilleure parce qu'on vienne branchement
téléphone de d'un coup ma jument belge
et les plus
bien que le valencien est clair mais moi
je veux qu'ils ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts quand j'ai vu ça j'ai préparé
pour handicapés pour en prendre le bus
tranquille au niveau rapidité elle est
pas mal quand même parce que c'est vrai
que c'est un bus qui passent vraiment il
est très très rapide ensuite y'a les
plaisirs de l'intérieur et du wifi tout
le temps donc c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment pas mal et en plus ça c'est si
vous handicapez et ça c'était vraiment
bien que tous deux réunionnais puissent
l'utiliser et avec la poussette surtout
c'était pas pratique vu qu'il fallait
une demi-heure avant plier la poussette
est là avec le nouveau bus est clair
c'est plus pratique puis on peut mettre
directement la poussette avec la rend
donc si je trouve ça super génial et et
puis pour les mamans corps et puis c'est
confortable
accessible plus confortable plus rapide
le réseau car jaune se recentre sur ses
missions et offre ainsi un service
conforme à ses obligations et répondant
aux besoins des usagers dans les
transports interurbains car jaune a
aussi développé une ligne touristique
qui relie les deux aéroports de l'île
jusqu'à saint-pierre et en passant par
les zones balnéaires pour plus
d'informations un numéro vert 0 800 400
1 125 ou le
www.cglpl.fr
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais